Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
My name is David Flanagan,
although, hopefully, you know me as Rawkode across
the Internet.
Today, we have an episode of Rawkode live
where we're gonna be talking about DevOps and
a thing that DevOps interview.
DevOps is a a very special term in
the technology industry these days. It means a
lot of things to a lot of different
people, but we're gonna set down today and
have a conversation, break it down, share what
you need to learn,
and, hopefully,
give you some knowledge that you need to
move on in your career.
Now joining me today is
Rawkode. Hey, man. How's it going?
Hello. How are you? So yeah. Nice to
meet you. Yeah. How are you?
I'm fine. Like yeah. I had, like, brief
of the talk sessions today, and I enjoyed
some meetings. So it was nice day, and,
hopefully, it is raining everywhere in Mumbai,
India. So we are having fun.
Awesome, Will. Thank you so much for joining
us today and coming here to have this
conversation, share some knowledge, and more importantly, have
a little bit of fun. So before
I ask you to introduce yourself, we've had
a few comments in the comment section already,
but people said hello. Please feel free to
say hello. And if you have any questions
that either of us can answer or help
you with today, please drop them into the
comment section. We love questions.
We're happy to sit here and do our
best to help you and everyone else. So
could you please say hello, introduce yourself, and
then we'll take it from there?
That's for you, Rohit.
Yeah. Yeah. So
okay. So hello,
everyone. So I'm Rohit Gumbre, and I'm from
Mumbai, India. And I'm currently working as a
developer at Rocketitesolo.io.
So
talking about myself, you know, on the Twitter
and LinkedIn, like, I'm sharing various resources on
the DevOps and talking about the DevOps in
various communities
as well as promoting the DevOps technology everywhere
as I can. So I am the guy
who can talk about DevOps, communities,
the well stuff,
and many more things. Currently,
I'm wearing various hats, like, you say ambassador,
you say developer, you say DevOps, I don't
get, or you can say the DevOps engineer
SRE role. So previously,
I had, like, lot of things.
Like, I didn't know how to land into
the DevOps
profiles
and developer advocate profiles.
But
if you come to my journey, you can
learn my journey, then it is like I
have done everything in the last two and
a half years.
So it is nice one. So we will
come to the journey part afterwards. But for
introduction
of myself, it is like, currently, I work
as a developer at so solo.io,
and I'm promoting the dev ops stuff. And
you can
learn more more thing about me on the
various open source platforms, like,
what we say, block platforms like Medium.
You can contact me on the GitHub
GitHub LinkedIn plat Twitter and many more platforms.
So, yeah, if you want to learn our
DevOps and envelopes, ping me anytime. I am
free. Yeah.
Yeah. I think that's the wonder I don't
know if it's wonderful. Maybe it's good and
bad. Right? But the wonderful thing about 2022
is that, you know, people are so approachable
now on so many different platforms. And I
would encourage anybody to send Twitter DMs to
either of us or emails or any of
the LinkedIn platforms, anything else. Like, you know,
people are there, and people generally don't mind
answering questions to help people. At least, I
mean, I I don't I don't think you
don't. I'm sure there are many more people
that does it. They're happy to answer questions.
Yeah.
Best thing about the online platform is, like,
I would give one tip to everyone. Like,
if you see, like, social media influencers or
digital nomads on the various platform like LinkedIn
and Twitter,
but they are having, like, 100 k followers
and one twenty k followers. So don't directly
reach out to them, I would suggest. Check
the other platforms where they are not that
much visible to people. Yeah. And, like, emails
are there for, like, team for collaboration type
of emails. And, otherwise, they have some platform
like Polywork or
other platform like Insta where they don't have
the followings. So they will easily reach out
to you. Like, they will reply to you.
So this is some of the best tips
I can say.
So this type of tips will come up
towards us.
Yeah. That signal versus noise ratio for people
on some platforms can be very
like, through no ill intent may just mess
your message. You're right. Like, you try and
find if you need to ask someone a
question, there's usually maybe other platforms or profiles
that you can go through. And I see
a friend of both of ours, Marino, in
the chat saying a % about approachability. So
hey, Marino. Thanks for joining We
already have our first question from Samantha. But
before we we tackle that, should we both
gonna share our our journeys and our stories
about where we are and how we got
to where we are today?
Yeah. You'll go first, and then I will
Hey. That's not how this works. Right. Okay.
Yeah. So I've been
try not to date myself too much. I've
been working professionally in software for twenty years
now.
So, I mean, I've wearing a lot of
hats. I have a lot of experience in
different things. But one thing that has remained
true for me throughout my entire career is
that I'm eternally curious.
I'm always always
playing with new technologies and trying to, you
know, expand my knowledge as much as possible.
And I think the reason I always share
that, and I always say it's like I'm
a bit of a technology magpie,
is that because I think that curiosity and
continuous learning is is so important. Like, there's
nothing
worse you can do as someone who wants
to be a
you know, end technology for their foreseeable future
is to get stagnant and stop learning because
the the technology landscape isn't stopping
by any means. I mean, let's look at
the last ten years. So I'm diversion already.
But, you know, we've went from DevOps to
SRE and cloud native and Kubernetes. Like, it's
just constant. You always have to build around
and do stuff. So there's one tip for
people's security.
However,
throughout my career, I've always ended up doing
operations in DevOps. I've been very lucky and
unlucky.
My first job was working for a company
where I was responsible for a better systems,
EPOS systems, Linux GUI applications. I had to
wear a lot of hats.
And we
were a small company in Glasgow, so we
also didn't have, like, this throw over the
wall mentality of operations.
I why it was operations? If I wrote
the code, I had to run it. And
that has that has stuck with me. And
probably the most viable thing I've I've taken
with me over the last twenty years is
that I've never
never not been responsible for my own code
in production. And I think that curse I
don't know. I don't mean to call it
a curse, but it makes you think a
lot about the things that you're you're shipping.
So I was very fortunate that
I wanted to improve that productionization
and deployment pipeline. So I very early got
into
Puffit when it first launched in 02/2006.
Migrated to SaltStack.
And when that came out, it must've been
like 02/2009. It was maybe a few years
after that.
As of that company, I did some consulting
for a while and then I ended up
being director of development for a media company.
And that was
that was, like, super hard for me because
I was writing less code, but I was
also still the only person that ever deployed
anything to production. So I was kinda still
doing the operational side.
And what I hadn't appreciated before that role
was this how to scale applications.
So this was my first company where my
application wasn't being used by 12 people on
a physical site. It was, like, all websites.
It was virtual. It was a company that
owned magazines and radio stations.
So our scale could be anywhere from
a hundred requests per second to 50,000 requests
per second, but I had never dealt with
that before.
So that was a very valuable learning experience
for me, and I actually dictated the next
five years of my life
moving into the container space because I needed
to be able to scale faster and virtual
machines are are quite slow. I mean, I
can go into all of this in more
detail, but I'm trying to not go on
for thirty minutes here.
And so we adopted containers and then I
found out a lot of people were trying
to adopt containers at the time. So I
actually went back to consulting and I found
I was speaking at more events about containers
and getting more gig. And I think that's
when I realized that I actually prefer
sharing knowledge and helping people than shipping products
or code or containers.
And I started speaking at more events. And
that's how I got into DevRel because I
was like, you know what? I do have
a lot of experience, and I wanna be
able to make other people's lives easier.
And because I'm always learning, I have this
continuous curiosity.
I I'm always learning new stuff that I
can also share, which is which is why
we're sat here. Right? Like, I wanna be
able to learn from my guests and share
that knowledge with other people. And I hope
that other people enjoy that too. So
I've been doing DevRel for the last five
years now,
mostly in the container cloud native Kubernetes space.
Really enjoying it. Currently working at Pulumi, which
is a very
not DevOps exactly, but definitely operation developer crossover
platform or tool.
So I'm very much keen to have this
conversation today.
So how about you share your story now,
please? Mhmm. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Also, it is
very nice to hear that you have you
have, like, diverse type of knowledge from consulting,
shipping to, like, having the developer advocacy, developer
relation. Best thing our developer relations is, like,
you can you are, like, learning every time.
It's like, you are having this conversation also.
You are having some knowledge. So I'm gaining
some knowledge. You are getting some knowledge. You
are having the mutual learning type of a
thing here. So, yeah, public sharing comes this
type of roles. So, yeah,
talking about my life journey is like
I my life journey started in 2020 lockdown.
Corona situation was there. And I was sitting
idly,
and I saw, like, yeah, I have done
nothing in my life.
I'm I'm just studying my bachelor's degree, and,
yeah, computer engineering is going slowly, slowly.
So I've I thought, like, I should do
something about this. I mean, I I am
learning the data science, but how means I'm
not enjoying that thing. So I learned about
machine learning, and then I saw, like, machine
learning can be integrated with various things. So
I learned about the data analysis, data visualization,
and how can you scrap the data,
move the data to various things. So, yeah,
it was going fun smoothly, and all data
science was fun. But it is like Spark
we have. Right? That Spark was not there.
So I thought, like, yeah, I should explore
other tracks also. Then I learned about the
Java and various tech Java and then product
development.
So I joined one
it's like it was, like, part time type
of a thing where I was working as
a school and developer. I was teaching assistant
also at the that small startup during my
college period, final year period. So it was
kind of all too. So it was fun.
Like, I was enjoying, but,
yeah, I didn't found that spot there also.
Then
I moved to the machine learning
integration with the various things. Right? So then
I come to know, like, there is a
cloud technologies out there There are hybrid multi
cloud. There is a
AWS cloud providers out there. Various flow cloud
providers are AWS, Azure, and GCP. Various type
of cloud providers are. So I saw, like,
that the it is nice platform. Like, we
can have various services, and it is helping
us to learn everything, and we can start
everything at just one click or, like, we
can have anything on the web UI, and
we can use that. So it was fun.
That type that time, I learned about the
DevOps technology. So when I was integrating the
machine learning with this technology, like, how can
we
deploy one machine learning model into the DevOps?
And I saw, like yeah. I mean, it's,
what
which thing I was doing manually. Like, I
was training that model, and I was finding
the error. And that again, that error, I'm
rectifying. I was thinking, like, yeah. This is
the error. So let's move again to the
previous step first step and, again, train that
model.
So it was hectic thing in the data
science field. So, yeah,
that time I learned, like, how can you
integrate the ML with the DevOps, and it
is, like, complete ML ops pipeline. So you
just have to deploy that model to the
DevOps pipeline, and it will train automatically for
you. You don't have to do anything after
that. So it is complete automation.
So, yeah, that spark I got that time,
and I enjoyed DevOps.
Then
after that, I joined one company as a
DevOps cloud engineer. It was fun, but that
company was has having some problems, so it
was start up. So then I moved to
another company that where I joined as NLP
and ML ops engineer type of role. So
it was fun. I enjoyed mostly
everything. Like, I learned about NLP,
can we integrate the machine learning with testing,
research and development part of things. So I
was working as a research and development
engineer, you can say. So I was checking
the papers
and learning from them and how can you
so in machine learning and DevOps,
DevOps is mostly about the tools. But if
you want to develop your tools, you have
to learn what other companies are doing. Right?
Cloud tech cloud native platforms are there. Projects
are there on the Linux foundation. It is
easily available. So you can check. And so
there are platform projects. You can check their
documents. So research about the things, how they
build, how their case studies were running. So
So I learned everything in the machine learning
field also and on the devs. So it
is never everything, but I tried to learn
everything. So I enjoyed that thing. So research
and development was fun. And
that company,
most
of the part of my work was going
to the machine learning. So what I did,
I thought, like, now is the time I
should move to
next part next time of next part of
my life. And, yeah, I joined as a
developer, okay, at solo.io.
And, yeah, developer relations is, like, fun. You
can explore anything, like, every
any technology you want. But I will suggest
go with the tech stack you already know.
So today,
there is a lot of hype in the
developer relations market. So everyone is trying to
get the developer relations role, developer advocacy role.
So I will suggest choose the tech stack
you know already and
company which is using that tech stack. So,
like, I'm in the solo dot I'm working
at the solo dot I o, the that
work on the Istio service mesh and
Silly and maybe be a flight technologies.
Similarly,
your Rawkode is
working David is working on the Pulumi.
So Pulumi is the infrastructure as a infrastructure
provisioning company. So you can launch the everything
in just one click type of a thing.
So it is also the DevOps kind of
a thing. So it is one of the
tool. So this type of a companies, have
to check-in the DevOps way. So similarly, I
did. I
so I know I I'm going to share,
like, what was the entire process to apply
to these jobs, how I got this job.
So previously,
I had various offers before this company.
It was senior senior
site reliability engineer role, site reliability engineer role,
DevOps engineer role. So how can you get
everything in this just one point five years
of experience and two years of experience? So
because everyone is reaching out to me on
the Twitter and LinkedIn, like, asking me, yeah.
Yeah, bro. How means, like, does refresher don't
get the DevOps jobs? So thing is in
in it's, like, not only Indian colleges, but
everywhere. Will thing is, like, they are teaching
you the teaching
you the tech
what we say?
Teaching you the things,
but
they are not giving the industrial learning. So
if you don't have the industrial learning, how
the companies will hire you? Right? You are
not doing any open source contribution. You are
not doing the
what actually needed for the interviews. Right? They're
just learning the theory knowledge. So what you
can do, and how can you get this
job interviews?
How can you go get the offers from
front side? Not you have to, like, apply
to the websites,
and then you will get the job. That
type of things are happening.
But there are different ways. We will discuss
it later.
So that was my journey till now. And,
yeah, currently, I'm working as a developer advocate.
So developer relations is also fun, but choose
the tech stack you know. So today's decision
will be completely on the DevOps. We will
discuss the devo developer relations kind of a
thing later. So, yeah,
this was my part of a journey in
the DevOps. So I currently, I know the
AWS
cloud providers,
GCP,
Azure,
and there are cloud native projects, some of
them, which is necessary for the DevOps technologies.
And, there are some products
out there. So you should,
know various things about this thing, and
there is a compulsion. Like, you should have
the certification also. So that is myth. Right?
If
I ask the David also, you have any
certification, global certification exam?
You are going in there?
Any type of a global certification.
So yeah. See, there it is a big
need in the market. Like, you should have
the
any global certification to get the DevOps roles.
So we will discuss everything. So yeah. Yeah.
I mean, I went through like, when the
Cloud Data Foundation did their CK and CKAD,
I I did do them, but I haven't
renewed them
for personal choice. I just didn't think that
they brought a lot of value to me
personally.
But I I'm curious about what other people
in the industry think. And there and also,
you mentioned there's a lot. You're joining there.
So thank you for sharing all that. Yeah.
But there's two things that stuck out to
me that I thought would be really cool
for us to dive into.
One, you mentioned DevOps,
CloudOps,
MLOps.
There was something else. So I'm curious
to you
what DevOps means.
And I know that this is a global
not global. There's, like, this
debate, I would say, in our industry about
whether it's a culture, whether it's a role,
whether it's a, you know, it's a an
idea and methodology.
There's a whole bunch there. So we'll dive
into that. But I'm also curious. Like, you
said you've been doing this since 2020,
so, like, two and a half years.
I wonder,
like, is it intimidating
for you, like or for anyone new to
this industry? Because, like, you come in and
right away, there's, like, containers and virtual machines
and clouds and DevOps and SRE and Kubernetes
and, like, wow. Like, I can't even imagine
what that would be like these days for
people that are coming new into our industry
just to be overwhelmed
and flooded with all these things that people
must be telling them they need to know.
And I I'm curious about how you found
that and what that was like for you.
Okay. Okay. So thing is, like, everyone is
getting the it's like, it is
hard to find the resources available on the
Internet
because no one is sharing with you. So
college student and beginner,
what they do, they ask the seniors. Right?
So but if senior is not doing the
DevOps job, so how can you ask them?
Right? So he's not no. He he didn't
know, like, how the how to get the
jobs in the DevOps. Right? But he will
share. Like, you are my junior, so I
will give some knowledge to you, like, some
type of we say in Hindi, like, it
is a yarn type of thing. So it
is like, they will give you those knowledge,
which they don't have. Like, do this thing,
do the DSA,
do the coding,
and then you can easily get the job.
But that is not a part.
That how I means how I got the
learning
of the DevOps and knowledge of the DevOps
is, like, I joined one of the courses
who are there.
It means, like, I didn't
pay anything to learn about DevOps or any
type of a technology.
First, I learned about data science in the
mid twenty twenty nineties, and and that that
time,
I did the course certification.
So I didn't go go into the deep
into that certification,
but just learning of that thing. So how
I get that certification? You can easily apply
for the financial aid. So Coursera has the
financial aid. Apply to that twelve days you
can have, you can easily get that course
for free. Wow.
Yeah. So many people don't know. So I
did a YouTube video and blog for the
same, and that blog has crossed 800,000,000
views. So you can
it is like yeah. It is it is
really big thing. So that that that blog
has spread me well. That is other thing.
But, yeah,
if you are sharing if you know anything,
share directly on the Internet. So anyone
not everyone has the knowledge which you you
have.
In 02/2019
in 02/1020,
if you met to me, I was similar
to any beginner. I didn't had any knowledge
and everything. Just the thing is, like, you
have to
start.
You have to start anything. Like, if you
want to learn the DevOps, go to my
Twitter threads or go to YouTube videos of
various people.
So Okay.
We know, like, various people. It's into the
DevOps. But, yeah, I will recommend some
certificate
what we say, YouTube channels. Like, there is
a Nana,
Tech World with Nana. Another is Rawkode. Rawkode
has some various
videos
awesome videos with the Just a few. Forecast
forecast of interviews
where
inviting various folks from various industries. So there
are DevOps people also. There are Cloudinary people
also and different type of job
roles are there. So other thing is, like,
there is. He's also saying that DevOps
various boot camps and things. So there are
you you
you should not focus on learning through this
YouTube and Twitter only. I would suggest go
to this cloud native projects and dev ops
technologies
and
read their docs. So that is a Terraform.
Right? Terraform is a infrastructure as a core.
Similarly,
Pulumi is there. Similarly,
Crossplane
is there.
They have the awesome documents.
But how what can you can do?
Learn the read their docs well. So they
have step by step installation
and then how they did that set the
setup.
Read that terms, smaller smaller terms, like, if
there is a word.
Let's take example of a word Istio. So
what is Istio? Google the Istio word, and
then Istio has a well versed document.
So this type of a thing you have
to do. You are already learning in the
college, universities college and universities that you are
reading big, big documents.
You are doing the assignments. So this is
nothing for you. So start.
Another thing is, like, how I did, I
I started with the DevOps, and I followed
one path. It is like you have to
clear Linux technology.
So learn about Linux well. So how how
well, I will suggest, don't you go into
deep into the security type of stuff.
So first of all, I am telling these
things on the path to get the job,
not to get the expert. So don't come
back to me and attack like, yeah, you
are or you are wrong. You should go
into the deep and learn DevOps in the
deep. So I will suggest to get the
job, this is the path I followed, and
you can follow follow if
you want. But I'm just recommending you. So
other thing is, like, I started first learning
about the Linux. So Linux, you have to
learn learn about the Red Hat Linux,
learn about the Ubuntu if you want, anything
you want. But thing is, like, clear the
what we say, that Linux command. So there
are different type of Linux command. So there
are networking command. There are SSH commands. So
as what is SSH? This is like local
hosting and server hosting type of link connection
between the protocols and server clients and server
systems.
So that type of commands you have to
learn. Then another step is, like, learn about
the Linux networking
fundamentals.
So thing is, like, if you are directly
diving into the tools
so thing is, like, when you are hearing
about the DevOps word,
people has that misunderstanding,
like, you have to learn every tool. So
don't go deep into the tools directly.
Learn about the
Linux and then networking fundamentals.
So networking fundamentals is, like, basics of networking,
not
completely
deep dive into the same because you you
are not going into the security and networking
kind of a role. You have you should
have some basics of networking for sure.
So clear the fundamentals,
then you can easily learn about anything in
the future.
After the networking is done, learn about the
containerization, I would suggest.
So containerization,
there are different kind
of tools. There are Docker. There is Cryo.
There is a Portman. So
there are different types of things. So learn
about them.
Docker,
many people say, like, what is a Docker?
So they say, if
there is one big example everyone knows, like,
this
thing is working on my computer. I don't
know if if it will work on my
manager's
PC.
So if Docker is there, you can directly
deploy it on on your computer
and share that link with your manager.
And they can easily view that link and,
yeah, your model is deployed or anything application
is deployed.
So Docker is similar to that. Other thing
is after containerization,
you should move to the orchestration part. So
you have learned the container.
Right? Docker, you have learned or you have
learned the. So orchestrate that. So you can't
do everything in just containerization.
You have to orchestrate that containers.
So, like, there is a thing
which is Kubernetes.
So Kubernetes,
there is a big, what do we say,
big hype in the market. Like, you should
learn about the Kubernetes to get the job.
You should learn about the Kubernetes. But I
have seen it is my experience. I don't
know, like, hey. It should have the everybody's
experience.
So
you need the Kubernetes for the interviews,
but when you get the job, they will
not give you the job for the it's
like live job to
work on the Kubernetes.
I don't know it has happened with everyone
because we are working in the cloud native
like, what we say. We are working in
the Kubernetes company,
but we don't know. But but if you
work in some companies,
I don't wanna take name,
but they they will not give you the
Kubernetes job. They just take your interviews for
the Kubernetes.
So I don't know. Like, you are taking
the interviews on the Kubernetes, but you are
not giving the job to the student,
job to the professionals who
who are you hiring.
So
that is different thing. So learn about the
orchestration.
So what is it what it will do?
It will scale your containers.
It will scale your website.
So if you are launching any website so
let's see. Like, I have my website. So
Lingtree
let's take example as a rockboardacademy.com.
So if
I am clicking on that website, I'm just
one person clicking on it. But there are
various people in this world who is clicking
on their website. So it it should handle
everything, every website. Right? So every person should
easily
handle that groups. I mean, it's like, see
that website and, yeah, I get my my
photo and
they will put there. So it is should
be visible to them clearly. Right? So that
is a part of orchestration.
So there are various things Kubernetes
and orchestration
platforms can do, but this is one thing
I'm just suggesting.
There are various alternatives for the Kubernetes also.
You can go and look out for that.
Another thing is after the orchestration,
I will suggest learn about the cloud providers
also,
and there is next part, which is CICD
pipeline. So cloud providers, what are the cloud
providers? I will just give you the brief.
So there are some companies,
AWS,
Azure,
GCP,
OCI.
So what are they doing?
They are providing you
there is also now. So that that is
another big competitor.
So let's take a name of them also.
So thing is when you are taking the
cloud providers, what they provide, they provide various
services to you. So thing services like if
you want to create any app, just write
the code in them.
You you
you can create the app without coding also.
So they provide that type of things also
now. Other thing is, like, if you want
to deploy the app, they can provide you
the platform for deploying also.
Another thing is, like, if you have if
you have that laptop,
it's like you you are seeing laptop.
You have this that system. So you can
use
this system virtually
so that virtual machines are provided by the
cloud providers.
So it is nice to learn everything about
these cloud providers, but, yeah, you should know
the fundamentals also. So that's why I'm sharing
this part,
which is alternate to the cloud cloud providers
also. So you can build this
this virtualization on your local system also. So
there are some
things like what we say on premises.
So that also you can learn.
After that, after you learn this thing, I
will suggest going to the CICD pipeline. So
what is CICD pipeline?
So full form of the CICD first, you
have to know. I'm I have seen horrible
type of acronyms for the CICD.
But, yeah, I will give you idea. It
is continuous
integration and continuous deployment, we say. So thing
is, like, what is CICD when
you are
having any
let's see.
Have you seen
in any company you are working? It is
MNC or any company.
You see, like, there is a build reports
or
you are getting the testing,
then you see, like, deploy that kind of
terms you have heard previously.
But how that terms internally work? How that
deployment is working? How the build success comes?
How the build failure comes?
So that part comes into the build, what
we say, CICD.
So there are various tools, which are, like,
Jenkins
Jenkins CI is there, Circle CI is there.
So today, we use the
GitOps also. GitOps is like that is and
various things are there. So what they are
doing,
let's take example of one project to go
go and tell.
So,
yeah, I think I missed one big part
of this thing. After the learning of the
Linux and networking, you should learn about the
SVN.
So what is SVN? GitHub,
and that is SCM
tools. So these tools are like yeah. GitHub
so when GitHub is like service
provisioning, it is doing. So whatever packages you
have, whatever code you have, you can store
it on the online type kind of a
thing. So that is done by the GitHub
and these companies.
So let's take example of one project. So
you have the GitHub.
You have stored the code inside. So then
use that code
and
create the Dockerfile of so Docker provides the
Dockerfile. Right? So create the Dockerfile and write
the code to
get that GitHub repository inside. So it will
install that application inside that Dockerfile,
and then you have some links.
So you have both of the things. Right?
So then what will our
CSID pipeline will do? Will take that code,
and they will automate that code. So, like,
if you want to integrate
you you want to deploy that application on
the server or any kind of a thing,
so they will take that code and connect
it with the
automation.
And then if it is successful,
then it will send the there are various
jobs. So in one of the job, it
will send the message to the developer. Right?
Yeah. Developer, your code is successfully
deployed,
and, yeah, you can enjoy your weekend.
But if it is not successful,
then it will go pre go to previous
job,
and it will it will show you a
health checks, like, red red red kind of
thing. And you don't enjoy your weekend?
Yeah. Yeah. And it will show, like, mail,
fail, errors, and, yeah, that kind of hectic
things have
have seen
by every kind of developer. So I don't
want to
I don't need to explain that things. Right?
Because every everyone has failed the same. So
that kind of a thing is done by
the our CSUD.
So after that
yeah. Today, GitOps is also
training inside this
CSUD.
So
learn about the GitOps, I would suggest, and
it is kind of a future kind of
a thing. So learn about it. So in
that, I think there is a Jenkins x
also now.
So previously, it was not there. So it
is nice tool.
So after that, you learn the CICD,
then it comes to monitoring tools. So you
have deployed the application, but in future, how
you will know, like, everything is going fine.
You don't has the your application is deployed
and yeah. But, like, this website is visible
to everyone.
So how will you will know that because
you have developed deployed the thing. Right? So
operations
comes under the monitoring.
So what kind of monitoring tools are there?
There are various monitoring tools are there. So
you know about the.
There is a. There is Grafana. There is
stack.
So there are various tools you have to
learn.
You can learn. You don't have to learn
everything. Right? So I will suggest whatever I
suggest you previously,
learn one one tool of anything for interviews.
Not going to learning everything. You don't have
to be expert on everything.
You just you should be learning one one
tool, and it should be, like,
intermediate kind of a thing. No. Don't you
don't need to master because it is impossible
to master any tool. Because if you learn
today and you will master that tool, today,
there will be next kind of a thing
which will be coming to the market and
it is trending. So what is what is
the use of your line? So you have
the knowledge. You should make the fundamentals clear,
not get
the close with low
relationship with your tool.
So, yeah,
once you learn this CSID and then then
you have learned the monitoring,
Monitoring is something like you are getting that
whatever you got into deployments and all, get
that query, put into the Prometheus or any
yeah.
Logstash or something.
So and
that Prometheus will give some
what we say, query to you that input
it into the your graph on our dashboard.
So you will see, like, which was beautiful,
which was, like, yeah, graph, that different kind
of graphs.
You will see, like, visualization and,
yeah, my mic's visualization. That kind of a
thing is there. So, yeah, if that is
you will see, like, yeah, this type of
strength
we have. These many people are
visualizing our website really well.
We don't have any downtime.
So this downtime,
this kind of things
you will learn once you go into this
deep dive into the DevOps.
But, yeah, I have shared,
I think, some of them
very well. But, yeah, you will learn about
various things other than this also. But I
think this is the necessary part
till now
to follow and get into the jobs of
the DevOps.
So, yeah, we will come to
various points again.
Stigations.
But
That is possibly the most comprehensive road map
for DevOps I have ever heard in my
life. Damn.
Now you covered everything there. So
I'm gonna look pretty much everything you've just
said there right back to Samad's question. Samad
is just asking,
I work as a cloud support engineer. I
have two and a half years experience with
vCenter, vSphere, Windows, Grafana. I had a special
DevOps profile. Like, I think that road map
well, my comments went off the screen, but
that that road map is, like, spot on.
And, you know, he also follows up saying
he does have some knowledge of AWS, Linux,
and Ansible. You covered that. You covered source
control,
the Linux layer in the primitives, containers, orchestration,
monitoring.
Everything was in there. So, like, just start
checking at those things one at a time,
picking up Yeah. Yeah. Once once you learn
about the infrastructure as a core, which is
Terraform
and Pulumi and
what another is a cross plan.
Once you learn about them
one of them, not all of them, you
can move to the infrastructure provisioning, which is
you mentioned Ansible.
So Ansible is the infrastructure provisioning. It is
like you can launch the
anything, like
if you have any files
in your folder.
So you can automate
to view that files, and you can check
any word. So if there is a word,
Rawkode is going to zoom in that file
of any some folder. So you can directly
view that file using the Linux commands also.
Some will talk that thing. But there is
a thing which is called an Ansible,
which will automate this thing on different systems
for you. So you you have different systems.
You can view anything on that systems just
by writing some
do we say,
Ansible code inventory.
So, yeah, that is the thing. Yeah. Learn
about the YML also, I would suggest. YML
is not necessary,
but learn our it is the easy language.
It is not different. Yeah.
It is similar to what we call as
a
it is I I if I think it
is similar to JSON. I don't know about
others, but I think it is really similar
kind of thing. Yeah. Go ahead. Okay. I'm
sorry for this to be in a bit.
No. All good, man. It's all good. So
here's a next question then from Harsh Kumar.
Is it possible to get remote jobs in
DevOps as a fresher with no prior experience
but having the relevant skills there. So do
you have any advice or tips?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I wanted to commit
come into this later, but, yeah, we can
have the possible opportunity now. So let's answer
that question.
So, yeah, remote jobs or any jobs you
are getting into DevOps, people have a myth,
like, you can't get as a fresher.
So I have done it. You can do
it too. So
how can you get? So there are various
platforms,
as I suggested, and there are projects on
the which is available everywhere. So cloud native
projects are there. There are platforms
like
there are platforms like
open source platforms like GitHub is there, and
there are GitHub is there. There are documents
of these companies also. Like, if we take
an example of a Pulumi.
So Pulumi has various docs. So go to
that docs,
learn about that docs,
and you know, like, this thing works like
this. So, yeah, how the pull Pulumi installation
is working? How the they are creating that
installation?
How can you indicate that you you don't
like you have the relearn skills, so you
can integrate that with another tools also.
Take that thing, build
up a demo,
write
the blog for it, or share the course
snippets on the LinkedIn platform or Twitter platform.
Will
see Rawkode
will see you, and then and then he
will reach out to you. Right? Yeah. You
have you are writing really nice blogs,
and you have done everything really well. You
are
miss,
we didn't knew, like, this can be done
like this also. So this this is happening
with their various employees of company. It is
not a fake thing I'm sharing. But, yeah,
if you are doing any real world use
case, some employees like me also don't know.
Like, it can be that type of users
also resolved by our product.
So that kind of a thing is done.
So you are you are building anything,
share
online.
Go on go go means, like, public sharing
is the best thing you can do. So
I always recommend that learn by doing and
public sharing is the best thing you can
do to get the jobs. So how it
is like, you are learning this you have
the relevant skills. Right? So build
the demos for it. Write the blogs or
post snippets. Screenshot it. Share on the LinkedIn.
Share on the Twitter.
And you are if sharing day by day,
use some hashtag. Like, many people follow a
hundred days of course or ninety days of
DevOps and
various type of things they follow. You can
follow the DevOps community hashtag also if you
want to recognize easily because I'm running that
community, so it will be helpful for you
also because I will return.
So that kind of a thing you can
do. So if you are doing this daily,
you will will get the reach. Because once
one day, you will not get the reach.
Yeah. Don't
get sad.
Like, I'm I'm not getting the reach, so
I should shop.
Wait for the twenty days or not twenty
days, ten, fifteen days, twenty days, and you
will see the results. People are recognizing
you. They will reach out to your DMs.
So teach us or, like,
help with this use case. You will get
the freelancing opportunities also easily if that company
is not reaching to you. Another thing of
open source contribution you can do, go to
that company's GitHub repository and see, like, what
kind of a core they are building,
what you can add into that.
Or third kind of a thing is, like,
communities.
So every company has a community. So, like,
our solo dot has a community. Go into
that communities,
what we say, communities, Slack channel or Discord
channel or forums
and re see, like,
read if you know that tool,
you can see, like, various employees are sorry.
Various users asking the doubts
or they are, like, having problem with anything.
Solve their doubts,
employees or developer advocate will see your efforts.
And, yeah, I I we will reach out
to you. We will ask for your guidance
or, yeah, in future, you can get the
jobs also. I have seen various people getting
jobs like this. I got the job by
Twitter reach out. So you can go to
anything. You can go you can get the
job by any so
this thing is happening. Like, I said, the
three steps to get the remote job. Fourth
is networking.
So now how you will grow your networking?
You will have you you should have submit
the CFPs in the various conferences.
One of this thing you can do. Second
thing, write the cool blocks.
So your blocks will reach out to various
people.
My blocks reach out to various people. That's
why it was one type of open source
contributions you can
validate.
Because if I'm doing any project or something,
but in future, if someone do does that
project also,
doesn't matter for you. Right? So what you
can do for now, you had done that
project. Right? So write the blog for it.
You
have the validation for that project. Right? In
future, if you are applying the any jobs,
you have any adding the your projects in
the resume or your website.
So you have the validation for your work.
Right? So similarly, if you are doing any
community sharing LinkedIn platform, like any that core
snippets you shared, right, public sharing. That is
also your validation of your work. So if
you have the validation of your work, it
is easy to get the jobs. You will
not get any problem.
So that things comes in the open source
contributions.
And another thing,
not
don't think, like
miss, many people
has many students has the afraid to write
the blogs or come to the video screen.
So first time when I was giving the
talk,
I was also I was also reading a
lot. So
miss, like being Indian, it is like means,
like what do we say? We are not
from the English speaking countries.
So it is some kind of a
thing
which affects us.
So
don't hesitate.
Go to if you have the knowledge, people
will people
will listen you if you don't speak well.
So if you have the relevant skills, do
these things which I have shared. You will
the guy you will get the jobs for
the show. So open source contribution can help
Sharing the things on the public publicly, it
will help you, like Twitter and LinkedIn.
Third,
giving the talks and workshops
conferences,
it will help you.
Fourth,
writing the blocks, open source contribution,
and core contributions.
And fifth, what I shared
I forgot.
So
so you can point if you want, and
let me know if you have any doubt.
Reach out to me and on my LinkedIn
platform or Twitter platform so you can add
that comment doubts on the comments section also.
I will answer them here only. Yeah.
Awesome. Great advice there for everyone to follow.
And I can agree more. Like, you know,
the one I wanna kinda highlight that I
think is really important is just sharing what
you learn, especially if you don't have a
lot of professional experience, being able to build
up that repertoire and that profile of just
being someone that goes out there and learn
stuff and shares it is is really, really
gonna help. Like,
there's just some amazing people out there sharing
content,
and we
need more of that. We definitely need more
of that. So one thing I would add
to what you've said is just like,
you know, what makes an experienced engineer isn't
how many jobs they've had. It's how many
times they've failed.
Right? We all learn through failures. So I
would encourage people that are new to to
DevOps and Kubernetes and containers and cloud and
CICD and all of this stuff that we
were talking about is that it's it's okay
to make mistakes and it's okay to get
things wrong because that just means that you're
learning. So
get really comfortable with that. I've been doing
this twenty years and I still make mistakes
every single week. And and
what what you get better at is recovering
from those mistakes quicker and learning from them
faster.
And that I think that's a really important
part of the learning that we try to
not sweep under the carpet or hide, but,
you know, we definitely
twenty years ago, you were vilified for mistakes.
Like, people would say, oh, you shouldn't have
a job and you're crap. And that's just
a horrible, horrible culture
in our industry. And I'm really glad to
see that getting
better and improving and everyone being a lot
more welcoming within the industry.
Yeah, get comfortable with failure and listen to
everything that's been said here because, you know,
Rohit is dropping a ton of knowledge here.
This is wonderful.
Alright. We have another question, which is kind
of adjacent to what we're talking about now
and one that I I think is a
really good question,
which is about data structures and algorithm.
The question is, I don't like DSA.
Nobody likes data structures and algorithms. I I
guarantee you, nobody likes them.
Will that impact
their DevOps journey? You wanna tackle this or
you want me to I can add some
points, and you can add some points. Because
I know, like, you you
you have some knowledge over this, and you
you would have some awesome
points to add. So let's let me add
some, and you can add others.
So data structures and algorithms.
About this thing, like DSA,
many people feel like DSA is only the
only the computer coding.
So computer coding is a different. Programming is
different. DSA is different.
So you should know first that all. So
DSA
in college, there it was DSA was
our subject.
So I have learned there, and I cleared.
I was happy. But after that, I didn't
had much contact with DSA. I just learned
about the programming like Python, and
there is Python, Groovy, and
I am starting to learn about the Go
because, see, I'm working as a DevOps engineer
and developer and don't know the Go language.
So
I don't know. Because thing is, like, you
you should you should learn
I I would suggest, like, learn one programming
language very well, and other, you can learn
easily afterwards.
So that is not a point. So
learn programming language. Data structure algorithms will not,
like,
learn the syntax well. So how why it
will disturb you in the DevOps general?
So DevOps only require the scripting.
So scripting is like Linux scripting, batch scripting,
and Groove scripting is there for the Jenkins
pipeline.
And there is another
scripting.
Today, Go scripting is there. So this scripting
is required to other thing is, like, the
telephone code if you are in in such
a support.
So that type of code is there. So
that also you you are doing the scripting.
So DSA will not impact you in your
cover. It doesn't impacted me. So, yeah, that
was my kind of knowledge in this thing.
So, yeah, David, you can add some points
here.
Yeah. Of course.
I just wanna pop a comment up because
it's just saying how awesome you are and
how informative this has been. So, yeah, I
just wanna echo that. Like, there's there's there's
so much cool stuff here. And to add
to what you're talking about, I agree.
I don't think I've ever been on a
DevOps
interview or even given a DevOps interview where
DSA has been important. So, like, if you
find that data structures and algorithms are a
particular weakness of yours, and that's fine, they
are for a lot of people. And DevOps
is a good way to to go and
and work with all these cool tools without
necessarily having to know how to reverse a
binary tree. Right? And to be honest,
I spent a lot of time in my
youth doing data structures and algorithm stuff, and
it's never really been that useful to me
in my entire career.
Because we've moved up the stack language like,
programming languages and standard libraries for programming languages,
have these things implemented for you. If you
need a priority queue, hey. It's in the
standard library. Do you need a heap? It's
in the standard library. Do you need a
hash map and do need to sort it?
It's in the standard library. Like, I can't
remember the last time I had to break
out any of these algorithms for day to
day work.
And I'm really disappointed as an industry to
see organizations
still present these questions to people at job
interviews because
I think all they do is confirm that
someone went to university or a college. And
I think we're progressed so much further beyond
that now in our industry. Like, we have
people coming from nontraditional backgrounds that don't have
that knowledge, and I think these are disadvantaged.
These interview style questions
are disadvantaged to them, and I don't think
that's fair. Because, again, we just don't need
to do this stuff day to day. Now
there are some
programming languages that don't have as complete standard
languages like Cs. If you're going for a
C job, maybe you do know need to
know recursion and how to work with binary
trees or macro trees or bubble sort or
quick select, any of these things. But
nine times out of 10 or even 99
times out of a hundred, these things just
are not applicable anymore. But I'd like to
see organizations
give people tests or not even just tests,
but be able to, through conversation,
judge someone's experience and what they're interested in
and what they're capable of without resorting to
these horrible whiteboard DSAs.
I I think we can do better, and
I hope that we do better.
So, yeah, DevOps, I I don't think it
will be a problem for you.
You're very unlikely to get DSA questions. And
if you don't wanna move on to engineering,
you just have to find the right organization
that knows how to speak developers and understand
developers and what they're capable of without resorting
to traditional whiteboard and style questions,
which
I still think a few far between right
now, but it is getting better.
Alright.
Cool.
Joined
us. He's saying he has the same mic
and headphones as you.
There we go. Yeah. I am I am
I am like, I I saw
this mic on Kunal's video only. So I
thought, like, yeah, it is nice mice because
Kunal is using, so it will it will
be nice. Right? So I bought one. Yeah.
Very cool.
Alright. Well, we are approaching about an hour
now. Is there anything you're gonna share some
resources with us today. Right? You're gonna you've
got a a repository that could be a
valuable resource for people to learn more about
everything that we spoke about today.
So I think we should show people that.
Do you want me to share my screen,
or would you like to share your screen?
Do you have preference? Yeah. Yeah. You can
share that screen, so I will explain on
the video. Yeah.
Alright.
Too many monitors.
Let me think.
There.
Cool.
Alright. So this is your GitHub
username.
So that is rawkode g zero zero.
You have a repository called dev ops underscore
books,
which people can check out. Do you wanna
tell us a little bit about this? Why
you why you started it and and who
it's for?
Yeah. Yeah. So thing is, like, it has
a books which is available
of various
dev ops what do we say? There are
various writers
which which are writing out the system designing,
and they are writing about DevOps,
Kubernetes,
Istio.
So they have various books which are e
freely available ebooks,
but
people are finding it hard to get that
resources easily. So what I did, I collected
everything, and I asked various people to add
that. I mean, whenever they find any books
or something, ebooks or something freely available,
can upload it to this web website, this
GitHub repository, and it is, like, open source
contribution for you also, and it will help
the other also. So it is, like, huge
library where everyone can see that,
what we say,
books and read about them. And, yeah, it
is fully available. You can read the books
here. Other thing is, like,
I would I would share my
what do we say? You can go to
my Twitter profile. So there are communities like
should I share share the screen?
Yeah. Sure. Go for it.
Oh, I guess I'm feeling some problem here.
Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Is my screen visible?
No. I don't think you're shading yet.
Is it sharing on your site? Because I
don't see anything.
I guess there is some problem with my
new Mac. I just bought a new Mac,
so that's why it doesn't have any sharing
type of access. So, yeah, no problem. You
can go to my
Twitter profile,
and I will explain the things. It is
like
there is a DevOps community
where you can
ask the doubts, and I will answer their
doubts or there are various people
available
on the DevOps community, which will share the
answer for you. So whatever questions you want,
we will answer for you. Another thing is,
like, you will you can use that hash
DevOps community
hashtag,
and that hashtag will help you to get
into the
it's like search on the
your search panel
as hashtag dev ops committee. And you will
see that previous resources I have shared. So
there are some dev ops road maps out
there that that are dev ops part, like,
how how I did my journey into the
same. Other thing is, like, there are various
courses available freely,
which is provided by various YouTubers and various
people. So you can easily find that on
my profile.
So another thing is, like, I will start
my newsletter to
soon
to share these resources into one page,
and you can easily
see that tweets and various resources easily in
the documented format.
So, yeah, there are my various blog websites,
and this is the thing. Yeah. You can
go check out everything for me. And another
thing is I will recommend highly
highly recommend you to go to the Rawkode
Academy Rawkode Academy,
that Twitter channel, and they have, like, nice
nice sessions. So go and check. So last
time, list,
you have to start as a means, like,
you have should you should have start. You
are not
far ahead of everyone into the DevOps
part.
You should start. Once you start, you will
get the things easily. So open source contribution
is the same also. You you should
small contribution make the big impact. So, yeah,
go ahead and yeah. Let's conclude, I guess.
If you have any questions other than this,
I would really like to share. So yeah.
Yeah. If anyone has any questions, please drop
them into the comment section. We'll we'll tackle
them in just a few minutes. I'll just
echo everyone should definitely
be following
here. So this is the profile. Lots of
good links here. There's a newsletter.
I love that you've got a nice little
kind of penned introduction as well just about
who you are. So yeah. Awesome.
And I wanna just point out this book's
list is awesome. Right? So there's books on
Ansible, AWS,
Azure.
Sorry. On you go. Other than this, I
I think we have missed one thing. It's
like MLOps kind of a thing. So I
will give the a little brief about ML
ops. It is like, if you know the
DevOps and machine learning, integrate that machine learning
and DevOps both. It is like machine learning
on DevOps. It's ML ops. So ML ops
is like monitoring the various machine learning models
easily.
So the today, I think it's like data
scientist is facing the problem to learn about
the various things. Like, data science data scientist
are
facing the problem to deploy the models. And
when they deploy the model, 60%
of their model goes into the
scrap.
So they have to look move again and
solve that errors and start again. So they
all solve that problem. So so it is
like if you deploy the model into the
CSID pipeline, it will automate for you. And
then after you do the automation,
and it will run the pipelines again and
again. So your code, you have written the
script in the that CSID, and it will
run that code for
again and again till you get that your
accuracy you which you want. So it is
nice. I have some blocks on the envelopes
also. You can go to my website, and
you can check that blocks.
I have some projects on the DevOps and
ML ops side also. You can check that.
So ML ops, how to line into the
ML ops? This is the best
career I will suggest for now because there
are only list companies working on the ML
ops. So you have you have the more
opportunity to go going to going into the
MLOps. So
learn about the ML into
basic basic,
like, of various
algorithms are there and then connect it into
the kind of a thing. So it is
easy. So as
David suggested, you don't need to learn deep
into the data structure. But
once you learn the Python, every every libraries
are there easily, which you can use that
library to build the packages, and
you can you
can build your own library also. So it
is not a issue. So, yeah,
thanks for having me, and, yeah, it was
nice. Yeah. So ask the questions if you
have. Everyone,
you can ask any questions you have, and
we will answer you for you. Another thing
is, like, there are various tools we have
not taken yet.
Under road map after this,
so there are various things after the basic
things has done. So, like, chaos engineering is
there, service meshes are there. Istio is there.
So if you want to learn anything about
the service mesh Istio, go to the solo.io
academy. So there are various
courses,
workshops we do for the same, and you
can find that easily.
And if you ask me also, I will
help you to learn about the service message
to you. Anything about DevOps, we will free
to answer you. Same thing you can ask
to the David also. He's he's really active
in the communities,
and
he has many hats. When you check his
profile, you will get understanding. Yeah.
Awesome.
Alright. I will include all of the links
and all of the resources that you have
mentioned today in the show notes below. So
anything that you've missed, they will be available
shortly after this episode.
The list of books in that repository are
just great.
I can't believe there are that many books
that are available for free. Like, that is
awesome.
I also I don't think we have any
more questions, but we do have some thank
yous. So we we got a thank you
there
from
from Hart. Thank you.
And another thank you there from SM and
So, yeah, I think we tackled both of
those questions. So thank you for watching and
joining us today.
Alright. I think that was perfect. Thank you
for joining me today and just sharing so
much knowledge about your journey and DevOps roadmap,
talking about ML ops. I mean, there's definitely
a lot interesting
things there that we could set and dive
into deep for another hour. I think we
could easily schedule
a Twitter space or another follow-up episode where
we go a bit deeper in some of
this. But I just wanna say thank you
for joining me again today
for sharing all that knowledge.
And I hope that we get to speak
against it.
So
any last words before I let you go
for today?
Yeah. Thank you for having me, and it
was fun. Like, yeah, David, connect let's connect
in future for
further episodes for this or, like, we can
have the Twitter spaces also where we can
invite various people on the same. So, yeah,
it was nice talking to you, and we
had a really great areas. So, yeah, thank
you. Thank you for joining. Alright. Thanks very
much. Alright. Everyone else, have a great day.
We will be back again soon. Until then,
enjoy
the weather. I don't know. Bye bye. Bye.
Thank you for watching Rawkode Live.